marie-laure car on est ce que l'on
appelle une responsable dévoué 1974 79
que ce soit la recherche d'une fiche et
la partie notre côté alors julien ou
d'un collègue perdu le rythme de la
journée particulièrement intense en ces
jours de portes ouvertes à la spa
il faut être partout pour informer
rassurer et conseillers on est quand
même une très grande structure on a
quand même à peu près de 150 chats au
refuge et une centaine de chiens
c'est beaucoup de paperasse et après on
est quand même beaucoup de salariés
beaucoup de bénévoles donc il ya tout ce
côté là chaque responsable le vit un peu
différemment après moi j'aime bien être
un petit peu
partout responsable du refuge de plaisir
depuis six ans la jeune femme consacre
toute sa vie aux animaux ici chats et
chiens sont recueillis par une quinzaine
de salariés pour espérer ensuite trouvé
une famille elle c'est une chatte que
nous avons récupéré de fourrière
justement qui qui a fait ces dix jours
de fourrière et malheureusement elle n'a
pas été récupéré par ses propriétaires
parce qu'elles n'étaient pas identifiées
donc quand on voit son comportement
on voit que c'est une à une une chatte
qui voilà qui al'habitude de l'humain
dont qui vivait obligatoirement dans un
foyer
et c'est justement dans le foyer
familial que marie laure va développer
sa passion pour les animaux petite fille
la chambre qu'elle partage avec sa soeur
se transforme en refuge son parcours est
alors tout tracé ont travaillé à
l'espèce un rêve de petite fille dont
chacun ses rêves mais le mien c'était
vraiment de travailler à la spa et donc
avec ma soeur ma soeur jumelle qui est
aussi responsable dans notre refuge donc
c'est très marrant on a le même parcours
on avait déjà plein d'animaux quand on
était petit on était déjà très
responsable puisqu'on se lever une heure
plus tôt on se lave et très tôt le matin
pour s'occuper de nos animaux donc tout
le monde trouvait une logique qu'on
finisse à faire de la protection animale
puisque depuis tout petit salon suite
depuis son engagement est total pour la
cause animale de ses débuts en 2001 en
tant que bénévole jusqu'à ses fonctions
de responsable à plaisir ses qualités
sont appréciés et reconnus par
l'ensemble de ses collègues avec marie
heures faisait partie de ces
responsables de refuges qui font bien à
mon sens bien leur travail dans le sens
où ils ont une éthique qui donc une
vraie éthique de protection animale à
accepter des animaux et pas toujours des
animaux facile parfois des vieux parfois
des animaux et du caractère
des animaux qui aura des petits soucis
de santé ça demande du travail demande
beaucoup d'investissement mais là on est
vraiment sur un refuge une super équipe
de salariés les bénévoles les aides il
ya vraiment une bonne équipe de salariés
et c'est top pour les animaux se
taillent et la dévotion que le porte
marie laure pour les animaux ne s'arrête
pas aux frontières du refuge à la maison
cinq chiens quatre chats une tortue et
des chevaux ont la chance de profiter de
sa passion